do you like over-the-top space battles
or do you prefer for star wars to open
with a joke we have our opinions so
here's every star wars movies opening
scene ranked
none of these opening scenes are
outright terrible but one has to come in
last and unfortunately that honor goes
to the most recent film the rise of
skywalker the most poorly reviewed in
the sequel trilogy the opening sequence
begins promisingly enough as the
starfield fades we see supreme leader
kylo ren as he plows through a group of
enemy combatants on the trail of the
resurrected emperor palpatine from there
however things quickly fall apart as the
sequence reveals the scene's true
intention ren's sole goal and his
slaughter is to find a tracking device
that will take him to the stormy planet
hexagonal it foreshadows the rest of the
film's interminable fetch quest plot
structure more importantly the sequence
walks back not only the plot character
and even design elements of the previous
film ryan johnson's the last jedi but
even director j.j abrams own sequel
trilogy opener the force awakens
the opening scene of the phantom menace
thrusts jedi knight qui-gon jinn and his
young apprentice obi-wan kenobi into a
bureaucratic taxation conflict between
the trade federation and the galactic
senate with a small planet of naboo
caught in the middle the sequence is not
all dry negotiations of course the trade
federation under the command of a
mysterious cloaked figure sends droid
soldiers to kill qui-gon and obi-wan and
a blaster against lightsaber battle
ensues but many of lucas's most
questionable choices in the film and
indeed the prequel trilogy as a whole
are already present we see the flat
direction and stilted dialogue that
defeats normally charismatic actors like
liam neeson and ewan mcgregor then
there's the decision to model several
alien species after specific ethnic
caricatures and of course there's a
preference for lightweight frictionless
cgi over the more tactile familiar
textures of models and makeup every star
wars opening scene works best as a
preview of the style and thematic
concerns that the rest of the film will
follow and phantom menace for better or
worse is exactly that
the last of the original trilogy
premiered in 1983 and return of the jedi
is a film whose structure bears more
than a little resemblance to the first
star wars film as in the original film
jedi spends much of its first act on the
desert planet tatooine and climaxes with
the rebels victory over the empire's
newly constructed death star one gets
the sense that lucas wanted a do-over on
certain parts of a new hope as if he
wanted to take advantage of the
technological and budgetary leaps made
since 1977 he effectively redoes the mos
eisley cantina scene with a far more
complex menagerie of aliens in jabba the
hunt's palace and he stages a bigger
busier death star battle than was
possible the first time around jedi's
opening scene establishes a new under
construction death star it also
establishes that darth vader is back in
a role as a subordinate as he was with
grandma turken and a new hope as he
arrives on the death star vader reveals
to the commander that the emperor will
be coming to oversee the completion of
the base it's an ominous scene that sets
up the climactic stakes of the last film
in the original trilogy that is correct
commander star wars was risking serious
audience fatigue when it released solo a
star wars story less than six months
after the last jedi not only that but
the production went through a
high-profile shake-up when original
directors phil lord and chris miller
were fired and replaced by filmmaker ron
howard resulting in well-publicized
reshoots if that weren't enough the film
was attempting to recast harrison ford's
han solo one of the most iconic pairings
of actor and character in film history
the resulting film is torn between
delivering a fun space adventure and
hitting every recognizable part of han
solo's backstory it bounces from
important moments like meeting his
wookie co-pilot chewbacca and winning
the millennium falcon from frenemy lando
calrissian to trivial beats like how he
got his blaster in the opening scene
howard directs the speeder chase through
the broken down shipyards of jung han's
home planet the scene is set to a
rousing and romantic new theme from
composer john williams but it becomes
bogged down by references to thermal
detonators the gold dice that will one
day hang in the falcon's cockpit and the
laughably unnecessary moment in which
han's clearly symbolic last name is
bestowed upon him
attack of the clones opens with an
explosion that rocks queen turned
senator padme amidala's ship as it lands
on the republic capital planet coruscant
the identity of the bomber and their
reasons for wanting padme dead are
treated as an important mystery as a
result obi-wan kenobi plays detective
while his apprentice anakin skywalker
violates his jedi oath by falling in
love with padme while serving as her
bodyguard
intrigue is not a color that star wars
paints with very often and it's
particularly difficult with prequels
audiences know from the start that the
ultimate culprit is newly elected
supreme chancellor palpatine who will
use a phony war to consolidate power on
the way to becoming emperor and destroy
the jedi still attack of the clones
leans into a 1940s detective vibe even
down to a bizarre retro diner where
kenobi gains a vital clue but while it's
fun to imagine a full-on film noir star
wars the movie ultimately isn't
interested in sustaining that vibe an
attack of the clones soon returns to the
more is more aesthetic that marks the
prequel trilogy as a whole
the second star wars film produced by
disney 2016's bleak prequel rogue one a
star wars story was beset by reshoots
and behind the scenes shakeups just as
solo would be two years later but the
finished film hangs together remarkably
well as they start consideration of
wartime sacrifice that affords no
last-minute rescue for its doomed rebel
spies
a tone is set in the film's opening
scene a flashback in which the pastoral
life of young gin urso and her family is
shattered by the arrival of imperial
troops her father galen was an imperial
scientist whose moral objections to
working on the death star forced him
into hiding but now the empire
represented by the slimy orson krennic
has come calling once again
you're hard man to find galen
but farming
young jin flees to an underground bunker
as her mother lira is shot down by
stormtroopers and galen is taken away to
finish his work on the deadly space
station the scene effectively lays out
the narrative and emotional stakes of
the rest of the film though it's also a
prime example of the disney tendency to
have everything important to a character
happen all at once
after a prequel trilogy's worth of trade
federation separatists count dooku and
general grievous jj abrams 2015 sequel
the force awakens announces its back to
the basics intentions in the first line
of the title crawl
here the original trilogy's characters
have become legends and inspirations to
the series new characters
when ace x-wing pilot poe dameron refers
to leia by her newly established rank of
general an old rebel ally smiles warmly
and replies for the general
to me she's royalty the opening scene
concerns the battle for a star map that
will reveal luke skywalker's whereabouts
and it structurally serves to introduce
most of the sequel trilogy's new
characters there's poe a hot shot pilot
whose cavalier personality gets him into
a fair bit of trouble we then meet dark
lord kylo ren who attacks lor san
tekka's desert village in search of the
star map next there's the conflicted
stormtrooper finn whose first taste of
combat leaves him traumatized and
looking for a way out then there's bb-8
a next-generation r2d2 with more
charisma and personality than many of
the prequel trilogy's human performers
only rey is missing from the sequence
just like luke in a new hope she shows
up after the intense opening action
sequence
after two films of political
conspiracies 2005's revenge of the sith
finally lands viewers in the middle of
an actual star war as obi-wan kenobi and
anakin skywalker raced to rescue
chancellor palpatine from the clutches
of sith lord count dooku and the
four-armed jedi killing droid general
grievous little do they know palpatine
is in fact dooku's evil master and that
the kidnapping was staged as part of his
years-long plan to rule the galaxy star
wars rarely takes full advantage of the
three-dimensionality of outer space
which makes it a pleasant surprise when
the camera pans down from obi-wan and
anakin's solitary interceptors to settle
on the gigantic battle raging just below
them hayden christensen still struggles
to infuse anakin with much charm or
passion but overall the film is
invigorated by being the final entry in
the prequel trilogy and last lucas can
show all the things audiences have been
waiting for from the fall of the
republic to the rise of darth vader
star wars has had its share of humor
often powered by the charisma of its
actors but it rarely tries to tell jokes
and among the types of jokes that a star
wars film would try to tell a prank
phone call would certainly be one of the
more unexpected but that's exactly what
happens at the start of ryan johnson's
the last jedi in the sequence poe damer
installs for time while his rocket
boosted x-wing powers up he hails the
first order commander general hux and
then pretends not to hear him as hux
blusters about in confusion one of his
captains has to explain the joke i
believe he's tooling with you sir but
johnson has more on his mind than making
star wars intentionally funny again as
seen in the rest of the opening scene it
features an intense battle sequence that
culminates in a disastrous bombing raid
the first of many defeats for the
resistance over the course of the film
like rogue one the last jedi is
concerned with what it means to
sacrifice oneself for a cause and how to
find hope within hopeless situations
johnson works through these themes in
both plot and character building a
poignant relationship between poe the
cocky flyboy who's never lost and leia
the hardened pragmatist who's lost too
much
in the 1970s and 80s sequels
particularly sci-fi sequels gave
audiences more of the same but cheaper
however the james bond series kept the
franchise fresh by offering interesting
new variations on the central theme with
each new entry in 1974 is the godfather
part 2 directed by george lucas's friend
and collaborator francis ford coppola
delivered a sequel that was both more
epic and more intimate than its
predecessor the empire strikes back
takes its cues from both bond and the
godfather it establishes many of the
elements that are essential to every
star wars film that followed while also
being unafraid to challenge its audience
with dark material its quick and dirty
opening scene strikes several opposites
from a new hope gone are the brown dry
deserts of tatooine and their place we
see the white frozen wasteland of hoth
luke skywalker gets a hero's entrance in
both films but this time he's suddenly
attacked and dragged away by a wild bomb
the stakes are immediately set when a
floating probe droid discovers the rebel
base and luke awakens in the frozen cave
of the vicious beast that attacked him
our heroes are not safe here and their
achievements in the previous movie
cannot save them
after 45 years and nearly a dozen films
in the series there is no opening scene
in star wars that can match that of a
new hope and impact spectacle and pure
storytelling potential as the film opens
the screen is filled with the impossibly
large shape of a star destroyer chasing
the fleeing tantavi iv blockade runner
within minutes we meet princess leia
darth vader r2d2 c3po and even the
ever-present stormtroopers but really
it's that scrappy rebel blockade runner
fleeing laser bolts as the endless
leviathan of a star destroyer slowly
fills the screen as it pursues that
truly sets the tone for the entire film
even if audiences hadn't read the
opening crawl establishing the broad
strokes of the rebellion's battle
against the empire it would be able to
know whose side were meant to be on from
the visuals alone the star wars
mythology has grown for decades across
movies books toys comics and games but
it has never outgrown the iconography of
those first indelible minutes from 1977.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you